yeah I'm cutting him I'm cutting him
Cayenne okay okay okay No hey guys
welcome to another episode of the
Wednesday checkup I'm wearing scrubs but
that's because I was reading your
comments and I see the same two words
over and over again surgeon simulator
but wait he's family medicine to see
even perform surgery be it known that
Mikhaylovich offski has a medicine and
surgical license in the state of New
York so basically what it is is that I'm
saying I think I'm gonna crush this game
I also have my scalpel here it's been
one of those days and I'm angry BAM
that wasn't as dramatic as I hoped
diazepam my man's getting high on benzos
okay we got a heart transplant here
hello sir my name is dr. Varsha offski
it's a pleasure to meet you I'm gonna
give you a nice little poke just to make
sure you're not awake hello sir
hello what do we got 22 seconds you have
five and a half liters of blood your
rhythm looks awful cuz that's not a real
rhythm I am going to go down and grab
this oh it did not grab get out of here
alright now we have the surgical field
and I have to do a heart transplant is
there a bone saw is there a bone saw in
the house there you go what what's going
on here yeah I'm cutting him I'm cutting
him crying okay okay okay oh dear no no
sir I am sorry please do not sue the
hospital for this time to knock these
ribs down why is he losing so much blood
let me get the old school bone saw okay
the hand goes up this is a weird way to
do it let's cut some bone no come on
this is the right way to do it
break those ribs why is my hand covered
in blood chop-chop
no nerado need to chop his lungs this is
the most frustrating thing I've ever
played and I play overwatch it's hammer
time cuz our patient has only 800 ml's
left he's basically dead
no yeah cut those ribs cut those ribs I
swear
real life is each brutal murderer cheese
in the mere 7 minutes and 32 seconds I
feel like I need to give give us a
second try hello sir my name is dr. Mike
Marsh off sky ok I know what we have to
do we're gonna raise it up first I'm
gonna angle it and then go in and there
you go ok no we don't want to cut long
whoop that looked like I was cutting the
liver I am sorry sir Oh there's so many
more ribs in the human body than what's
shown here it looks like there's like
four ribs okay okay let's get this
breastbone out of here let's take out
this lung what does it stuck on yeah get
that lung out of here Hey
okay wait am i guys dying sorry I
promise we don't have this much fun in
the operating room
no it's not what I eat it my fingers
stuck okay what is happening this is not
realistic at all
and my surgical views obstructed but I
need to cut these ribs out so yeah no no
my patient has only two liters of blood
left
oh no wiggle it free and why did I kill
my patient even faster this time all
right I got this I got through med
school I should be able to get through
this why is there a bottle of soda on
the field we're gonna tilt his hand and
pick up the sternum if this was real
life I would have lost my medical
license like 20 times over again okay
sir I'm not even gonna say hi to you cuz
I'm a surgeon and we don't say hello to
our patients I'm just kidding I love
surgeons
no we don't want to cut his stomach all
right the rib is broken let's get this
out of the way yeah boy oh my watch fell
off you know patients have actually okay
my patients thank me all right
the patient's liver is just floating out
of here okay let's get this out of here
the right lung let's get it out of here
this is not the way you perform surgery
gently over the stomach and cut out oh
look at that cut you know you like that
cut that's a plastic surgery incision
right there
get that esophagus out of here BAM now I
have the heart
I think I'm cutting it out no no no no
no no the heart what are you how did I
lose the scalpel
it's the heart loose the patient's
bleeding out looks like I'm murdering my
patient okay let's try and get the new
heart out I got the heart the heart is
live drop it in oh wait I got a deed now
I know why someone said in a review of
this game that this was a comedy because
literally all I did was chopped his
incorrect number of ribs off after I
chopped them off and threw his lungs off
to the sides which by the way weren't
connected to anything because I didn't
cut the lungs out proceeded to butcher
his aorta and pulmonary artery and vein
and don't even take his heart out go
into the transplant bin where the new
heart is on ice and then chuck it it's
his chest and apparently that surgery
complete I can't finish off with a score
of d do you have hope for me because I
am hoping myself I think is kind of rude
to just start bashing him with a hammer
so I'm gonna go in and get this first
see Andrews and whites taking points
away from me for this I'm cutting is
along a little bit that's okay
breathe along breathe along there you go
lung is free let's get it out of here
this log is just sticking out of his
body I grabbed it like a football there
you go
get it out of here my watch even came
off I'm so passionate about it all right
there's a lot of blood in the surgical
field I'm just gonna go right for the
heart and see if that's a good way to do
it okay heart
why is that not it okay I need to go in
and make good okay
he's grabbing the scalpel all wrong and
now he's causing my patient to die
Oh my patient now it's a stupid side of
him this game is probably so much more
fun in virtual reality oh it worked
I got a D again this game is really hard
mostly because it's very poorly made and
it's clearly a common it's not a real
game I want to continue playing more
games I want to do more reviews so if
you're up for it smash the like button
get this video to 20k likes guess what I
will make the video where I go out and
buy all sorts of board games video games
whenever I can find on the shelves and
play them on camera stay happy and
healthy
[Music]